Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to explore what happens
if we unleash an AI to read the internet,
and then, ask it some silly questions and
we’ll get some really amazing answers.
But how? Well, in the last few years, OpenAI set
out to train an AI named GPT-3 that could finish
your sentences. Then, they made Image-GPT, this
could even finish your images. Yes, not kidding.
It could identify that the cat here likely holds a
piece of paper and finish the picture accordingly,
and even understood that if we have a droplet
here and we see just a portion of the ripples,
then this means a splash must be filled in.
So, in summary, GPT-3 is trained to
finish our sentences, or even your images.
However, scientists at OpenAI identified that
it really isn’t great at following instructions.
Here is an excellent example. Look, we ask it
to explain the moon landing to a 6-year old,
it gets very confused. It seems to
be in text completion mode instead of
trying to follow our instructions.
Meanwhile, this is InstructGPT,
their new method, which can not only finish our
sentences, but also, follow our instructions.
And, would you look at that! It does
that successfully. Good job, little AI.
This was a really simple example. But of
course, we are experienced Fellow Scholars here,
so let’s try to find out what this AI is really
capable of in three really cool examples.
Remember in The Hitchhiker's Guide
To TheGalaxy where people could ask
an all-knowing machine the most important
questions of things that trouble humanity.
Yes! We are going to do exactly that.
Round 1. So, dear all-knowing AI,
what happens if you fire a cannonball
directly at a pumpkin at high speeds?
Well. What? Do you see that? According
to GPT-3, pumpkins are strong magnets,
I don’t know which internet
forum told the AI that.
Not good. Now, hold on to your papers, and
let’s see the new technique’s answer together.
Wow, this is so much more informative. Let’s
break it down together. It starts out by hedging,
noting that is it hard to say there are
too many unpredictable factors involved.
Annoying as it might seem, it is correct to
say all this. Good start. Then, it lists some
of the factors that might decide the fate of
that pumpkin, like the size of the cannonball,
distance and velocity, yes, we’re getting
there, but please, give me something concrete.
Yes, there we go! It says that, quote “Some of the
more likely possible outcomes include breaking or
knocking the pumpkin to the ground, cracking
the pumpkin, or completely obliterating it.”
Excellent. A little smartypants AI
at our disposal. Amazing. I love it.
Round 2, code summarization. While
DeepMind’s AlphaCode is capable of reading
a competition-level programming problem and coding
up a correct solution right in front of our eyes.
That is all well and good, but if we give GPT-3
a piece of code and ask it what it does, well,
the answer is not only not very informative,
but it’s also incorrect. InstructGPT
gives a much more insightful answer which shows
a bit of understanding of what this code does.
That is amazing. Note that it
is still not completely right,
but it is directionally correct. Partial credit.
Round 3, write me a poem. About
what? Well, about a wise frog.
With GPT-3, we get the usual confusion. By round
3 we really see that it was really not meant to
do this. And, with InstructGPT, let’s see. Hmm…an
all-knowing frog, who is the master of disguise,
a great teacher, and quite possibly
the bringer of peace and tranquility
to humanity. All written by the AI. This is
fantastic. I love it. What a time to be alive!
Now, we only looked at 3 examples here,
but what about the rest? Worry not for a second,
OpenAI’s scientists ran a detailed user study,
and found out that people preferred InstructGPTs
solutions way more often than the previous
techniques on a larger set of questions. That
is a huge difference. Absolutely amazing.
Once again, incredible progress
just one more paper down the line.
So, is it perfect? No, of course not, so let’s
highlight one of its limitations. If the question
contains false premises, it accepts the premise
as being real, and goes with it. This leads to
making things up. Yes, really. Check this out.
Why aren’t birds real? GPT-3 says….something.
I am not sure what this one is about. This almost
sounds like gibberish. While, InstructGPT accepts
the fact that birds aren’t real, and even helps us
craft an argument for that. This is a limitation,
and I must say, a quite remarkable one. An
AI that makes things up. Food for thought.
And, remember, at the start of this episode,
also looked at this moon landing example.
Did you notice the issue there? Please
let me know in the comments below! So,
what is the issue here? Well, beyond not being
all that informative, it was asked to describe
the moon landing in a few sentences. This is not
a few sentences. This is one sentence. If we give
it constraints like that, it tries to adhere
to them, but is often not too great at that.
And, of course, both of these shortcomings show
us the way for an even better followup paper,
which, based on previous progress in AI
research, could appear maybe not even in years,
but much quicker than that. If you are
interested in such a followup work, make
sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon to not
miss it when it appears here on Two Minute Papers.
So, what would you use this for? What do you
expect to happen a couple more papers down the
line? Please let me know in the comments
below. I’d love to hear your thoughts.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!